l élection municipale à trappes est donc
annulée le tribunal administratif saisi
par othman nasri principal représentant
de l'opposition a rendu son verdict
annulé l'élection d'ali rabais ce
dernier devra rendre son écharpe
tricolore
une peine d'inéligibilité d'un an est
également prononcé des décisions qui
s'accompagne d'une validation du rejet
des comptes de campagne
il est reproché à lies rabais d'avoir
utilisé son association kurde sera pour
promouvoir son image pendant la campagne
et pendant l'entre-deux-tours entraînant
ainsi la confusion auprès des électeurs
le principal intéressé a d'ores et déjà
annoncé faire appel du verdict auprès du
conseil d'état contacté par nickel et
demi d'euros ils nous considèrent ils
considèrent à ne rien avoir à se
reprocher eh bien je suis très surpris
par la décision du tribunal
administratif qui contredit les
conclusions de la rapporteur public qui
avait plaidé totalement en notre faveur
et dans le cadre de fêtes contradiction
entre la porta public et les juges du
tribunal administratif
je donnerai le dernier mot au conseil
d'état qui est l'instance d'appel
c'est pourquoi je fais appel
officiellement auprès du conseil d'état
qui lui fera dans les mois qui viennent
pour dire si cette élection doit être
annulée ou pas quoi qu'il en soit je
suis serein je n'ai toujours été plus de
ma relation trappistes elle est claire
et limpide il pas pourquoi j'ai été élu
pour mettre en oeuvre quels progrès
peintres hollande il voit la qualité de
notre travail avec l'ensemble de mon
équipe depuis maintenant huit mois et on
continuera sur le même rythme dans les
mois qui viennent et quelle que soit
l'issue du monde du compte ce n'est pas
à la fin on sera pas trop rapide pierre
le mobile en mai à l'appel étant
suspensif à lire à berre restera en
poste jusqu'à la décision du conseil
d'état qui pourrait intervenir avant
l'été
écoutez la réaction d'hotman nasri
conseiller municipal d'opposition à
l'origine du recours au quai par michael
élimineront le tribunal administratif de
versailles et vient confirmer
aujourd'hui ce qu'on répète depuis des
bourrasques on disait avant même
l'élection à savoir que monsieur rabais
affichés durant cette élection n'a pas
respecté les règles électorales et est
inquiétant pour l'avenir de la ville
contrairement à ce qu'il dit son
problème il y parle avec moi avec
monsieur avril avec la justice la
commission des comptes de campagne
kémaliste ratissons a également séduit
tribunal après avoir rejeté ces groupes
et contrairement
qui l'a dit parce qu'il n'a cessé de
mentir aux trafics le tribunal a déclaré
aujourd'hui que les comptes avaient été
rejetées à juste titre que les comptes
de campagne n'incluait pas des dépenses
électorales qui est un manquement grave
aux règles électorales
et c'est en cela que la l'élection est
annulée mais également que sera déclaré
ilie l'egypte et donc il lui appartient
de s'expliquer il ya des procédures en
justice n'ont jusque là on a attendu
tranquillement ce jugement quel qu'ait
pu être aidé insu j'ai été traitée de
donald trump de trappes mais moi je
respecte à justin je répétais vue autre
réaction à vous proposer celle de
l'ancien maire de trappes jusqu'en 2020
et guy malandain il a été à la tête de
la ville pendant 19 ans aujourd'hui dans
l'opposition il n'exclut pas de se
représenter en cas de nouveau scrutin
une revanche contre ali rabais qui fut
son adjoint durant le mandat précédent
il a été joint par mélanie poker le
droit doit être respecté et en priorité
les respecter parce qu'ils ont des
mandats électoraux et donc les décisions
du tribunal prouve que ne ce rappel n'a
pas respecté le droit et vu le
comportement qu'il a eu samedi lors du
conseil municipal où rien mépris les
critiques permanentes sur ce que j'avais
fait avec mes amis dans le mandat dans
le mandat précédent
c'est bien que tout cela fait cette
annulation de l'élection municipale si
elle est confirmée pourrait également
remettre les cartes au sein de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
qu'en pense le président de la
collectivité voici sa réponse au micro
d'astrid bergia il faut quelque chose de
vrai vous savez il ya le marketing les
candidats exagère toujours un petit peu
chaque année mais là on est plus dans
n'est plus dans l'ordre les règles on
est en dehors des règles c c'est
vraiment des techniques de pression de
maquillage des informations de
d'utilisation de 2,2 des moyens qui sont
qu'ils sont illégaux puisque c'est pour
ça que la justice est intervenue là on a
dépassé
je veux dire on a franchi
l'infranchissable avec monsieur rabais
mais en cas de nouvelle élection le
président de saint quentin en yvelines
espèrent un plus large rassemblement la
tête de la ville toutes sensibilités
politiques confondues
on sait ce qu'il faut pour travaux le
tout c'est que il faut trouver des
moyens il faut que la il faut que la
nouvelle équipe qui cette collectivité
soit cette trappe
il faut qu elle il faut qu'elle ait le
soutien des puissants aussi un que soit
le département la région en 50 1 50-1
fait 50 % quasiment du moyen de trappes
donc il faut que tous ces gens là que
qu'ils soient de gauche ou droite mais
qu'ils aient cette volonté de travailler
ensemble et puis dernière réaction à
vous proposer celle de philippe
benassaya député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines celle à
laquelle appartient trappe l'élu de
droite apporte son soutien à celui qui
est également aujourd'hui son suppléant
à l'assemblée nationale autre menace
rouge j'ai suivi son recours juridique
est exclu
son action pour pouvoir faire éclater la
vérité puisqu'il ya quand même il y
avait quand même pas mal pas mal de
problèmes sur la tête de dali rabais
j'ai suivi les suisses en sait jamais
simple d'aller voter
quel que soit le camp politique c'est
s'est jamais simple parce que on fait
revoter la population moyennant un peu
plus d'un an après les élections donc il
faut remobiliser dans les deux camps
c'est pas évident d'abord pour le maire
sortant parce que il commence une action
municipale et elle est annulée pour
laisser graves dont on a parlé un
instant que dans l'autre camp il ya une
remobilisation à effectuer c'est pas
facile aussi pour othman al-othmane
menace roues